c'est nouvelle qui va réjouir tous les
militants de la protection animale ce
matin la ministre de la transition
écologique qui s'appelle comment barbara
pompili way dont une au pompidou à
l'annoncé que la présence d'animaux
sauvages dans les cirques itinérants
allait être interdite
eh oui si pour l'instant aucune date
n'est fixée la décision a été prise
regardez petit récap je vous annonce la
fin progressive de la présence de faune
sauvages dans les cirques itinérants la
fin de la présence d'or et de dauphins
dans les delphinariums inadaptées à
leurs besoins de mammifères marins la
fin des élevages de visons pour leur
fourrure en france et le soutien aux
actions collectives des parcs
zoologiques pour l'amélioration des
conditions de détention des animaux
c'est une transformation progressive de
ces secteurs que nous engageons une
transformation qui ne doit pas être
pensé contre les professionnels
concernés mais bien avec eux alors voilà
alors vous réagissez chez vous tiens
est-ce qu'elle a bien fait barbara
pompili d'interdire les animaux sauvages
dans les cirques ça c'est un truc c'est
un gros gros débat gilles verdez vous
dites quoi énorme débat moi je suis pour
franchement il fallait le faire non il
ya 500 fauves qui sont concernés et
franchement les dauphins et les orques
dans les delphinariums un or qui avaient
prouvé qu'en captivité ils meurent des
années plutôt qu à l état sauvage il
peut pas faire c'est 180 km il est
contraint et forcé il fallait arrêter
tous importe qu'elle a fait l'erreur qui
pendant un an ben oui oui parce que
c'est une question de timing
pourquoi aujourd'hui on est en pleine
crise sociale on est en pleine crise
sanitaire
elle nous annonce que le gouvernement va
débloquer 10 millions d'euros je suis
désolé mais est ce que là il n'y a pas
un combat un tout petit peu plus urgents
à mener
on est tous d'accord voilà on veut des
renaître de la faune sauvage mois par là
franchement est-ce que c'est l'urgence
sur non je suis désolé après il ya des
séries inspirées la langue
c'est vrai certains la crème de dire que
les animaux c'est pas la priorité
on n'aurait pas dû consentir à des êtres
humains on s'est presque pour s'occuper
des êtres humains et des animaux le
coeur humain est assez grand or
plusieurs causes en même temps excuse
moi mais il était urgent de s'occuper
des animaux tu y es tu peux poser un
tabouret dans la savane du printemps de
dix ans il n'y a pas un enfant qui va
s'asseoir dessus
tu vas pas monté sur un honneur qui
faire du rodéo on afflige des choses aux
animaux pour leur faire faire des choses
pour le public faut arrêter ça c'est une
souffrance pour les animaux des cirques
les animaux dans les eaux peut-être les
émissions qui sont en qui sont en voie
de disparition mais autrement les sondés
dans l'est dans leur jeune milieu
naturel de la vie à un petit peu c'est
pas interdire certains animaux tu peux
pas dire arbitrairement faut supprimer
tous les animaux sauvages des cirques
ses banques mais non ces animaux qui
sont nés en captivité nous revenus que
ça il me semble
les gens qui les maltraitent mais tu
t'en vas
or s'il vous plaît prenez ouais mais
justement mais il appelle une fois ou
deux fois
je suis là qu elle à michèle chay du cje
en péril par sa mère non mais on peut
mener des actions parallèles voilà et
les animaux en catimini sonner un
activiste 1 401 captivité peux pas mais
il se met à captivité parce que tu lis
en captivité les parades mais même s'il
tient la plume captivité ou des animaux
je regarde quels documents animalier et
moi quelle ou un animal et à plus d'un
lycée que certains états des animaux le
problème c'est que le directeur de
communication de marineland qui s'est
exprimée a dit quand même que ça se
faisait vraiment un peu trop à la hâte
et killer préféré en parler en amont
avec le gouvernement parce que le
gouvernement va demander des castration
chimique
et il pense que ça va aussi traumatisé
les animaux d'une autre façon que de
leur faire subir ce qu'ils vivent
actuellement
donc il aurait aimé que ça se fasse
moins vite et qu'on puisse discuter
ensemble pour le faire au mieux aussi
pour les animaux plutôt que ça on va
voir ce qu'on pensait spectateurs
regardent et oui à 77% non à 23% donc
c'est un plébiscite à victor hugo disait
torts hugo disait c'est important
l'enfer n'existe pas pour les animaux
existe
déjà away we go qui disent ça et on les
casse et avenue